c'è un tipo che spara picchio fischio lo
picchio che sto picchiando aiuto ma io
abbia fatto male finché pietro vendicami
si il buon amico vendicari stai schivato
tutti i colpi vai vai sarebbe stato
bellissimo non è simpatico accanto
all'altro
niente e quindi hanno fatto anche a me
non muoverti non hanno muoverti ne
capisco c'è la guerra dei mondi è
totalmente invisibile mag
quel tizio nero di fronte alle ha
scoraggiato e abbastanza ceco non si
muova va bene il governo è stato
bellissimo e sono la cosa più bello però
ecco di eccoli acli che attraverso la
musica dei quattro jobs sta più che bene
mi fanno sistema attiva
[Musica]
sì secondo me perché ha sentito la
musichetta regala ceca cosa stiamo
giocando ma che meraviglia ora ho capito
la puntata a terra sono forte io vanno
sotto come mele ci apre c'è male madonna
che brutta cosa vedo vieni pure manager
e via vai coi muri riesci a come vada
perso no due muri di memorizzino muri
bravo 11 vai a mano allora no scusami
ho fatto una cosa bruttissima meno
merito vedove
no non volevo farlo scusa ma da due
esseri animato style a sky
ecco vado al cicr edo vai vai vai vai ma
come niente di vita allora con una
stoccata sotto sul niente diritta o mio
dio
vai vai vai vai vai vero spaccare tutto
spacca sciatrici kill anch'io
no forse manca un 3 bravo facciamo
vedere a ciccio gamer che non siamo
capaci solo grazie a lui e l'ho buttato
per terra fa vj signori number one
vai vai lasciano lascialo parolin che fa
spider man dove di mi sa che qua dentro
sento camminare qua
ma è andato andato giù ciao amico
seguendo via servirebbero prova beh
sprechiamo vabbè sprechiamo tante
vedente tenta mi spiego sto trick ve lo
dico ragazzi anche se lo sapete già
tutti se ti butti prima in acqua perchè
tutti si apre dopo e quindi 20 giu
guarda che non si gioca e pietro guarda
impara si gioca così pietra devi capire
che si gioca e così eccolo qua sono
sopra sono sopra dove si è passato tu
una terra favorendo così
non sarà una moretta no non equa
andate dai vai vai in grande ora queste
mio nonno è rotto ritorna su torna su
torna su lui caduta nuda vedi parlato
salvato la vita
grazie ciccio ok hai buttato giù ma
piace un altro che ora è andato il
latina è bravissimo
allora chi di voi cosa scarna sega
grande come sempre come sempre ho detto
ho proibito servendo dai maledizione
ebro scemo ride è tutta la giornata
una terra o grandi che si fa vuota team
così che si fa così con due tu stai a 25
davanti a noi 60 resta qui e lui quello
forte non io
davanti a noci esattamente davanti a noi
porca vacca quanta gente
ma dopo il casino uno lo porti natura
non lo so e l'altro no io ho colpito un
bel po
no è morto è morto bravissima mandato ci
vieni vieni debitorie che arrivava alla
fip dov'è a va bene dove va bene così
sta lì ok grazie bottino per noi gli
andai nel magazzino un ufficio mercato
bifronte ho detto io vado dove si lancia
ciccio che aiutati ok
seguiamo le persone che sanno giocare
che non ci sono tutti scarsi avuto un
problema di comunicazione iniziale mi
piace effettivamente la puoi smettere di
tirare fumo c nella mia stanza magagna
non vedo neanche la porta dai che
passino prego prego ci nora che non vedo
niente non è possibile dove questa
uscita ma che haga l'ho colpito forte su
due
destra ma dai
ho scolpito lo so come ho fatto me la
cosa buona ma non ci credo
pronti a saltare quando ve lo dico io ok
esaltate no mi dispiace non fanno freddo
ma che male
guarda mai sono piquet striscia ciccio
guardami sono stato utile
andiamo a bordo di planck dov'è
[Musica]
rischiamo carico le date una portata
schiena non schiacciato spazio
un bravissimo però siamo partiti da dio
no comunque è un casino bislacco c'è un
bordello
quindi occhio che moriamo andiamo subito
in una casa a tutti e due
come quella sinistra sì quella questa
qua è ok
bisogna che qualcuno
si sente la gente che viene qua ma noi
ha
come equa cavalca vista che cambiamo è
poco presente
non lo so non so non credo che una
revolver
non ho niente niente zero ore
[Musica]